más de 10 mil millones de personas a
finales de siglo es Igualmente
distribuidas por el planeta según un
informe de la ONU ocho países
representarán la mitad del aumento de la
población mundial en 2050 entre ellos
India Egipto Nigeria y filipinas para el
fondo de población de las Naciones
Unidas la verdadera cuestión que debe
plantearse es el derecho de las mujeres
a controlar su propio cuerpo en todo el
mundo según los informes el 44% de las
mujeres no tiene acceso a métodos
anticonceptivos
la cuestión no es si la población humana
Es demasiado grande o demasiado pequeña
la cuestión es si todo el mundo puede
ejercer su derecho fundamental a elegir
el número y el espaciamiento de sus
hijos desgraciadamente La respuesta es
un rotundo no
de todo el planeta solo Europa
registrará un descenso global de la
población de aquí a 2050 a diferencia de
los países de África muchos de los
cuales tienen las tasas de natalidad
elevadas otros datos la esperanza de
vida ha aumentado en 10 años desde 1990
pero de nuevo de forma desigual entre
los países pobres y ricos la agencia de
la ONU también hace una distinción entre
el Boom demográfico y el calentamiento
global el aumento de la temperatura no
estaría directamente relacionado con la
superpoblación sino con la actividad
Industrial humana los países que verán
aumentar su población se encuentran
entre los que menos CO2 emiten al tiempo
que serán de los primeros en verse
afectados por las consecuencias del
cambio climático